let's try our next caller from the 949
area code caller from 949 what's your
name where you calling from what's on
your mind hello my name is Isaiah and
I'm from Orange County California great
what's up uh and I was hello
and I was wondering David at this point
how likely do you think that the US will
engage in some sort of offensive war
with UN and North you know and what
would that look like and with someone
like myself living in SoCal be in danger
at all boy I mean let me answer the
second question first Isaiah I have many
criticisms of American foreign policy
and how the military is used but I would
like to think that our technology would
keep you safe in Southern California or
anywhere in the United States from a
North Korean attack or an attack from
another nation call me naive I don't
know I'd like to think that and you know
I'm not a military expert so I'm sure
there's people who could tell me more
specifically here's why I'm writer
here's why I'm wrong in terms of the
likelihood I think it is less than 50/50
but I do think that there is a good
chance that there is going to be some
degree of an incursion with North Korea
I don't know if I'd say it's about a
third chance right like a 33% chance or
40% what it would look like is really
the question and the complexity with
North Korea is that unless you're
talking about some kind of hyper precise
probably like covert ops type stuff I
don't know how you do an incursion in
North Korea that will achieve
significant political change without
hurting or killing innocent civilians
and I don't know if you have a thought
about that I don't know how you do it oh
yeah secular talk has often been saying
that he thinks like sixty-five chance
65% chance okay no yeah like a high
likelihood and he thinks that yes you
would kill hundreds of thousands of
innocent people because the North would
likely launch on Seoul yeah a way yep I
think that's
of all and I think it is you know the
only thing that's making me think it's
not going to go further is that every
five days we have very similar comments
from North Korea but they don't actually
seem to experience that their talk
suggests it's been now three generations
this is the one thing Isaiah that I'm
kind of banking on it's now been three
generations of vocally belligerent North
Korean leaders who have not actually
flipped the switch to or pressed the red
button that would be basically signing
their own killing so that's the one
thing I'm sort of hoping for that would
prevent this from escalating I don't
know if you agree with that
oh no yeah I think that the North would
never launch an attack but don't you
think that with you know Donald Trump
and how unstable he is and yet his low
favor abilities then he would be the one
to watch I think that's quite you know
and start I think it's quite possible
anything you wanted to say on this Pat
you wanted sure we do have those nuclear
bombers going back on 24-hour alert we
did that story earlier in the week it
also Air Force pilots coming out of
retirement at the same time so that's
concerning and then I'll see you a
Donald Trump meeting with military
leaders saying that this is the calm
before the storm what that storm is we
don't really know yet yeah we don't know
what though yeah we don't know what the
meaning is of a lot of these things and
the 24 hour bombers thing in the pilots
it could relate to Syria it could relate
to North Korea it might be a political
posturing move I don't know all right
Isaiah thanks very much for the call I
appreciate it thank you all right very
good